this is lorenzo he fell in love with
jenna i think my favorite thing about
jenna is her ability
just to embrace who she is as a puppy
puppy play is an extremely important in
my relationship
[Music]
what a great way to start and introduce
somebody imagine you just introducing
your girlfriend or something
man i just love my girlfriend i love
that she knows how to be yourself as a
[ __ ] hey man teach their own maybe this
is just a form of reparations
that's where a lot of like my my love
languages
lie despite living a puppy dream
this canine couple have had to deal with
some harsh judgment
i definitely do get a lot of hate this
person is just absolutely
mental like out of their mind
when we're in public it can be a little
bit embarrassing at times the thing
that's most crazy
it's not even the fact that she's on all
four it's the kiss to the dog but that's
that's you know
her own kind her own species he's their
own i guess
oh she got knee pads imagine trying to
be 16 trying to still live that
lifestyle
which i hope you do your stretches
because it's going to be tough on their
knees and those hips
trying to be like that forever and i
know there's some others out there
that got the weirdest boners out there
it's okay she really sleep in that cage
like a dog
it's just a way of submission it's just
the the her kink is her whole life now
which it's funny but it like i
imagine like here comes a bride this
girl just comes in on a dress on all
fours
imagine if he brings imagine if he
brings another girl home
he brings another girl home and he's
like what the [ __ ] is thi hey hey
shut up shush no back in your cage
then he [ __ ] a girl and then a girl
gets out of her cage
and just do like a dog and just just
stir that yo having a pet watch you bang
is one of the weirdest things
i met jenna at a photo shoot last year
we sort of clicked almost right away on
set by photo shoot do you mean
adult stuff no maybe just petsmart
you know advertisement he was shooting
and just like okay bring the next dog
damn that's a fine [ __ ]
after they met there was one thing that
jenna had to make sure
lorenzo was on board with so i started
first
pretending that i was a puppy when i was
really really little i would ask my mom
to play with the dogs with me so i would
just be one of the dogs and my parents
always asked
when i was gonna grow out of it but
i never did jenna lives a puppy
lifestyle
and had to make sure lorenzo would be
the right owner for all her puppy needs
when i first told him about this he
didn't shy away at all
he just was like okay cool like
so what do i need to do so
puppy play really was something that
i've learned a lot
of from jenna some of her needs and
feelings
uh are very similar you know to having a
puppy which
i've never personally have have had but
uh
you know it's something that i feel that
i
personally love embracing
puppy play is extremely important in my
relationship
that's where a lot of like my my love
languages
lie that's not a love language that's a
kink
stop it stop no
no no
that makes the most sense no this is not
no
you down you imagine if the sixth love
language is treated like a
you know i mean there's like there's
like physical touch physical touch words
of affirmation yeah
right or um you know gifting and then
number six
feel like a [ __ ] um i it's very
important
to get a lot of praise a lot of you know
good job you're doing great you know
good girls
[Music]
what i like about being a dog is the
bond
between like that one special person
like your owner
and yeah like the day-to-day like
mannerisms of a dog
that they have you know i like to be
very carefree
i like not having you know a choice
because it makes life so much easier
this is probably where i feel the safest
at home
it's kind of like my den it's like my my
area that i can retire to and know that
i'm safe and you know no one can get me
the first time i saw the cage i was
i was sort of shocked and it was a lot
bigger
than i thought but once it was set up
and i saw just how happy she was and
comfortable
she she really looks getting happy and i
i think it makes a great addition to the
room
showing their puppy love on social media
has led to people
questioning their roles in the
relationship some of the
most negative comments it's probably
just people saying that i'm crazy
this person is just absolutely mental
like out of their mind
a lot of people have said like you know
are you being
held against your will is he forcing you
to do this like
blink twice if you're okay i know myself
that i'm not hurting anybody
if you just slapped a brazer's logo on
this it would make way more sense yeah
but 100 sounds more real than reality
you know you got a problem
but percent she has only been i'm not in
trouble
i i'm just kind of living my life out on
the internet and with that comes a lot
of judgment
i try to comfort her and let her know
that there may be
a minority of people that feel a certain
negative way about you
but you still have me that do care about
you and love what you do
we're gonna go to the park and i'm
thinking we'll get some usual shots of
you walking on a leash take some video
some photos part of me thinks a lot of
this is for clout i'm not gonna even lie
to you
i think this is like a clout gimmick yes
and it works
but what if we throw a frisbee and you
catch it in my mouth
and your mouth that's right and if you
catch it in your mouth you know what you
get right
do i get a treat only if you catch it
this is definitely clap
this is clout chasing at its finest
all right i'm off
sit sit
[Music]
good girl you want to go to the park
shut it off why'd you stand up start it
off shut it off
how to yank that lease and be like busy
get back on all fours okay yeah this is
a gimmick no it's looking at me this is
a marketing gimmick
that's it i'm gonna finish it let's see
if she catches the frisbee
going to the dog park okay so i think
all these shots are set up because
there's no way she's consistently
walking on her knees like that without
new pets i refuse to believe she's
walking on cement that way absolutely so
for me i'm leaning off this is all a
gimmick
it is okay her pants are not dirty yeah
yeah i noticed that too
[Music]
when we're in public everybody stops
everybody that's a mom
right now and did some cleaning or
everybody that's a dad at this leaning
i didn't have kids everybody that did
some cleaning and had to remove
grass stains off of you you know
right now and you know you know i have
to remove my own grass
stains on my not because i'm walking on
four but doing baseball doing whatever
sports and
track and field and you know what this
is this is like a child who really wants
to believe they're special so they just
do weird stuff to feel special
that's what this is i don't care about
kings kids is a real thing
and it's okay live your kinks and
everything and stuff but telling me that
you
live that every day and it's like that
no i know that's the clown i don't
believe it that's a clown if you shut
down internet she stops doing that and
if
they don't are not together no more the
truth is going to start to come out well
it's popular right now it's popular
right now to do the whole shock thing
and try to be super different
yeah it pays bills so that's what she's
doing but you know
i was kind of curious because i saw the
video i times like oh
but the one i watch it the more this
looks like a gimmick so no
those are my thoughts no my girl came to
me one day and said walk me around on a
leash i mean you could do it for that
for the time that it's been but you
can't i can't see that you can live your
life like that also doing in public is
the weird thing exactly
you know i mean like people are not
uncomfortable because you do this in the
price of your bedroom they're weirded
out
because you feel the need to take that
out worth you know so yeah if i walked
around i saw some lady in a dominatrix
outfit just working her magic on a dude
in a public street
i might think that's a little weird i'm
just saying but you know we're just
living our king
no no your attention horror no your
attention no you know what i'm saying
that's what you're doing listen what you
doing the price of your bedroom most
people don't care you feel the need to
broadcast that
and then go out in public areas and do
that yeah that looks a little weird
you know but that's okay that's your
thing but don't make me try to make me
believe that you live like that every
day
and you're like you imagine if you're at
the park with your kids and then you
guys
stumble upon that what is the lady doing
that's not a lady she wants to be a cell
phone that she sells i didn't divide as
a dog
hey man no here's what it is tell us
what you guys think
no stop that that's enough
[Music]
foreign